there are over 240 testimonies from
current and former pupils at highgate
school
detailing allegations of abuse and
misogyny by other pupils
with some accusing the school of
covering up a rape culture
sarah not her real name says she was
sexually abused
in her classroom there was this boy and
he would constantly message me and send
me explicit pictures and i never
responded
and in class this boy while my teacher
was there under the table
slid his hand all the way up my skirt i
yelped and got up and ran out the
classroom
i was sitting in a spanish lesson when
he messaged me saying i'm going to kill
you
i will end you unless you come here now
when i told my school
i told them everything that happened and
they essentially twisted everything i
told them against me
and they took cctv footage of me at the
time when he grabbed me towards him
and they saw i was laughing and said
well you're laughing in this video so we
don't believe
anything you're saying highgate is one
of many leading schools that have been
named in more than 10 000
sexual abuse or harassment allegations
posted on the website everyone's invited
another former student from the school
who doesn't want to be identified
says the misogynistic culture began
early and was not discouraged by
teachers
i remember when i was in year 7 looking
at a boy's ask fm
account and he'd been asked to rate
every girl in his class
and i remember i was rated the lowest of
all the girls in the class
and i was so upset by it and the school
said they knew that boys had accounts on
ask fm
they knew that this happened but they
didn't reprimand the boys or anything
and what kind of signal do you think
that sent out to the
to the boys who are doing this the
school basically implicitly told them it
was okay to objectify the girls
and upset them in that way this me too
moment for pupils has snowballed to
other schools in the state sector and in
universities
today the government responded
announcing a new dedicated support
helpline
and a review of safeguarding policies in
schools
we do have some of the very best and
strongest safeguarding practices
uh in this country of any country but we
recognize that we always want to go
further we always want to do more
to protect the interests of children and
also
ensure that if there are v where where
there are victims that
their concerns are properly addressed in
a statement highgate school said we
treat any allegation of sexual assault
and rape with the utmost seriousness
we are committed to an external
independent review
of all these extremely serious
allegations led by the right honourable
dame
ann rafferty but alleged victims say
more needs to be done to address
a boy's will be boys attitude and a
tolerance which they say
has cultivated this behavior jason
farrell sky news